Well,
I think,
you know,
there's a couple of very important
dimensions to consider here.
We haven't seen a lot of,
of change in public opinion about
climate change.
Um,
uh,
were,
in part because of the downturn in the
economy where we're at,
uh,
an Arab in terms of public enthusiasm,
for action on climate change and concern
over climate change.
Um,
and that's somewhat part of a natural
cycle that you see on,
on social problems generally.
And on environmental problems sort of at
the height of concern about climate
change was around 2007,
uh,
with the release of income,
inconvenient truth in a record amount
of,
of news,
attention to that issue.
But it's almost as if the public became
a habituated or use or desensitized to a
lot of the stories and the narratives
about environmental impacts and
environmental disaster that we're at the
really strongly featured a around that
time.
And,
uh,
and,
and with the performance of the economy,
uh,
we started moving into a downward cycle
of concern.
So the oil spill hasn't really changed
or shifted,
uh,
that,
that period that we're in right now in
terms of an issue or a issue fatigue
with,
uh,
with climate change.
But what we have seen is a major change
in public opinion when it comes to
asking the public about weighing the
importance of either economic growth or,
or energy or exploration with the need
for environmental protection or
conservation.
Um,
uh,
between,
the month before,
according to Gallup polls,
the month before the oil spill.
And then roughly a month and a half
afterwards,
we saw that a majority of the public
literally reversed course that,
uh,
that before the oil spill,
the majority of the public favored
energy exploration on economic
development over environmental
protection.
Uh,
six weeks later that public preference
had flipped.
And I think that's something that's been
overlooked in the discussion.
There's been a lot of blame on the
administration and on environmental
groups for not taking advantage of this
major focusing event.
But in fact,
I think there has been a lot of the
news.
The news attention has done the work for
an environmental groups and has opened
up an opportunity,
at least a latent sentiment to think
about environmental protection over
economic growth.
Even in this period of economic
recession.